on attendait avec impatience
l'adaptation au cinéma par anne fontaine
du best-seller d'edouard louis en finir
avec des belles gueules 400000
exemplaires vendus le film sera enfin
cette semaine il s'appelle marvin
tiens donc et edouard louis a pris ses
distances avec le film à sa demande ni
son nom ni le titre du livre
d'apparaître au générique n'est pas né à
l'auteur qui se reconnaîtra dans une
dans une adaptation de son oeuvre bonne
adaptation cinéma c'est une adaptation
transgressive
il faut surtout pas adapté un très bon
livre au cinéma tel quel et pour cause
ce n'est pas vraiment le roman lui-même
qui intéressait la réalisatrice mais
edouard louis écrivain parcours hors du
commun qui a tiré d'un coup les micros
et les caméras lui même ceci est une
forme de fascination et curiosité parce
que c'est un très jeune écrivain il
avait 21 ans à l'époque
dans son livre edouard louis tirer
définitivement un trait sur son enfance
infernal persécuté pour son
homosexualité dans une france ultra
précaire il a fait une entrée par
effraction dans la littérature sont
arrimés et fracassantes et assez
bouleversante parce que c'est un livre
qui est arrivé comme une boule de feu
quoi
c'est ce phénomène la réinvention de soi
que raconte marvin vraie-fausse
adaptation d'un vrai faux roman nouvel
épisode de la saga et 10 belles gueules
qui n'en finit pas de se déployer
[Musique]
le livre s'intitule en finir avec eddy
belle gueule c'est aux éditions du seuil
roman tient donc roman qui est il ce
eddy belle gueule tout a commencé dans
les fauteuils d'une grande librairie à
la télé celle de françois busnel sur
france 5 un soir de janvier 2014
l'animateur faisait découvrir à des
centaines de milliers de téléspectateurs
une gueule une voix celle du jeune
edouard louis visage poupon et bagues
dentaires
si belle gueule et avait donc c'était
moi en fait se dire cette non oui
c'était moi avant que avant que je le
tue avant que je décide d'en faire autre
chose
il s'appelait eddy belle gueule du temps
où il était ce jeune garçon efféminé
ostracisés dans son collège son village
sa famille en picardie à 20 ans il
montait à paris intègre et normale sup
et devenait enfin lui edouard louis
écrivain je me souviens très bien du
moment j'ai reçu ce livre les épreuves
puisque les les critiques reçoivent des
épreuves donc c'était en décembre
et très vite dès les premières pages
étaient totalement happé par cette
écriture par le milieu qui était décrit
et qui est très peu représentée en
littérature et je dois avouer que ma
fascination pour ce texte a été re
doublé quand j'ai compris là aussi très
rapidement qu'il s'agissait non pas
d'une fiction médard et si bien que le
terme roman soit soit inscrit sur la
couverture du livre un roman où tout est
vrai un auteur qui passe en un temps
record d'enfants rejeté à petit prince
de saint germain des prés du pain béni
pour certains médias qui se sont emparés
du cas belle gueule pour enquêter sur
son passé on a essayé de vérifier avec
du réel si ce qu'ils disent est vrai
faux après il ya eu des journalistes
sont allés voir les parents qui étaient
assez bouleversée c'est un livre que
choquant pour les parents c'est choquant
et dérangeant derrière le transfuge de
classe et ça il en parle très très bien
il ya toujours un soupçon de trahison
comment il a pu pour en arriver là et là
forcément du trail air trahir les siens
on oublie alors qu'il s'agit d'un roman
et edouard louis se retrouve à justifier
l'injustifiable
avec un peu de recul deux ans plus tard
il reviendra sur cette polémique
on reprochait de décrire un monde qui
n'existait pas selon ces gens en fait
une sorte de monde fictionnel et la
bourgeoisie qui disait de ce monde de
mon enfance de ce monde preuve de mon
enfance au sein peut pas exister se
rendait pas compte de la violence que ça
représentait dire
un nouveau chapitre le magnétisme
d'edouard louis son texte puissant
attire très vite les producteurs de
cinéma
le premier à dégainer son chéquier pour
acquérir les droits du livre propose à
andré téchiné d'enfer adaptation mais le
projet ne se fait pas finalement c'est
anne fontaine qui va s'emparer de
l'histoire d'edouard louis a c'est lui
qui est venu vers moi
oui ça m'a étonné ben ça va étonner ça
étonne toujours de que quelqu'un ait
pensé à vous pour une histoire comme
celle-là j'ai tout de suite pensé que si
je mens paraître cette histoire ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est de voir comment ce
jeune marvin bon alors tentant lui il
savait pas marine mais allez pouvoir
s'extraire se construire à partir d'une
enfance telle que celle là est donc là
la trajectoire la quête initiatique
bouleversante ce jeune garçon qui va
arriver à devenir quelqu'un d'autre à
s'inventer une vie ça ça me paraissait
passionnante
c'est donc moins et des belles gueules
qu'edouard louis qui intéresse anne
fontaine la réalisatrice de nettoyage à
sec et coco avant chanel m ce personnage
parti de rien pour finir en pleine
lumière
[Musique]
isabelle huppert par ligne tu verras
c'est un garçon très intéressant mais
j'en doute pas dans le film edit belle
gueule s'appelle marvin bijoux il ne vit
plus en picardie mais dans les vosges
restait encore le scalène c'est pas bon
on retrouve vraiment dans toutes les
parties qui concerne l'enfance du
personnage des passages du livre le
l'enfant est surnommé squelette
exactement comme dans le livre il ya des
anecdotes qui sont celles du livre même
le la scène d'ouverture où le jeune eddy
belle gueule reçoit les crachats de ces
de ses bourreaux de collège et
totalement fidèle au roman en finir avec
eddy belle gueule est effectivement là
on sort de l'adaptation littérale c'est
lorsque anne fontaine raconte la presse
la réalisatrice a choisi de transposer
son personnage il ne devient plus
écrivain mes comédiens incarné par
finnegan oldfield un physique du nord
comme edouard louis
mais il a malgré tout pris soin de ne
pas jouer le mimétisme avec l'écrivain
le lit je l'avais lu avant d'avoir le
scénario est ensuite chez kant quand
anne fontaine
voilà ma montre et ses narines marvin
etc je vais demander s'il fallait pas
que je relise le livre elle m'a dit au
contraire il est vraiment qu'on
s'éloigne quelque part c'était le livre
donc c'était là la jeunesse du film le
point de départ mais je voulais vraiment
écrire et raconter une histoire
différente ce n'est pas la même histoire
et donc pas une adaptation alors qu'en a
pensé edouard louis contacter l'auteur
n'a pas donné suite à notre demande
d'interview il pouvait dire non je suis
pas d'accord je veux pas vendre mes
droits à quelqu'un qui transgressent
l'adaptation mais je pense que il là il
a eu l'intelligence de savoir qu'un film
c'était autre chose et que une
adaptation réussie c'est une adaptation
progressive
n'empêche en septembre dernier edouard
louis s'est fendu d'un tweet peu amènes
je n'ai rien à voir avec le film d'anne
fontaine n'a souhaité prendre ses
distances tout de suite précisé au
moment où les premières images de la
bande-annonce ont été diffusés que son
nom ne figurait pas au générique
pas plus que le titre de son de son
roman en finir avec eddy bergen et qui
n'avait donc rien à voir avec ce film
vous savez s'il doit lui a vu le film je
sais qu'une version non définitive n'a
été présentée et qu'il avait déjà fait
part de ses réserves au moment de la
lecture du scénario et qui les a
confirmés à la vision visionnage de ceux
de cette version de racheter le
producteur du film assume l'éloignement
avec le livre et donc ne cherche pas à
tout prix l'assentiment des douars louis
à partir du moment où anne fontaine
inventer une nouvelle trajectoire au
personnage et qu'elle lui donnait un
nouveau nom une part et c'est tout à
fait naturel qu edouard louis près de
dix ans par rapport à cette histoire
parce que c'était plus la sienne marine
bijoux et parisy belle gueule on est
toujours dans cette cette frontière
assez flou entre la fiction et le réel
et qu'on retrouve dans l'adaptation
d'anne fontaine sac assez intéressant et
troublant dans le film le héros triomphe
au théâtre dans une pièce que tout
arrive bien applaudir miroir à peine
déformant du succès littéraire et
commerciales d'edouard louis
semble ne jamais se tarir je n'arrive
pas à retirer dès à table enfin du bon
allez maintenant on va mettre d'autres
sol mais quand je dois tous les mois
combien encore revendre ce livre en
poche maintenant dans sa seconde vie
c'est considérable ces 15 20 30 ce qui
est très rare
ce qui est très très rare ce livre
continue sa vie sa vie est longue
[Musique]